You may have images that work fine on
a low-resolution desktop monitor but
look terrible on a high DPI display.
Not a problem, we'll just save
an image with larger dimensions.
That wallaby's a lot happier now.
Trouble is, we're now serving
a bigger image file to everyone,
whether they need it or not.
And that's going to result in a terrible
experience on a slow network,
especially you know, on a smaller
screen with lower resolution.
The problem with the plain
old image source
attribute is that it only
gives one URL for one image.
What if you want to provide
alternative files for the same image?
So the browser can choose the best
option for the view port size and
device capabilities.
Source set to the rescue.
Here we added a source set
attribute to our image element.
The syntax here simply means
that the browser should choose
the high resolution of wallaby_2x.jpg
for a higher DPI display, or
the lower resolution of
wallaby_1x.jpg otherwise.
The 1x, 2x syntax is called
a Pixel Density Descriptor.
And if we check from the dev
tools using emulation mode for
a 1x device, you'll see that only
the 1x image has been loaded.
Nice wallaby.
By the way, I've added a 1x
descriptor after the 1x image source,
but that's the default.
Different screens have different
pixel densities, more or
less dots of color per square inch,
the, the physical pixels.
And the more dots per inch,
the higher resolution the display and
the greater the pixel density.
But Standard laptop and desktop monitors
are regarded as being 1x displays,
whereas devices such has high spec
laptops and phones can be 2x or more.
Everyday, there are more and more new
screens with different pixel densities.
You can check this from
the dev tools console,
by looking at the device pixel ratio for
your display.
Here, the device pixel ratio is 1.75 for
my monitor.
And, now I'm using remote debugging for
my phone with the dev tools, and
you can see our device picks
our ratio there, is three.
You can find out more
about pixel density,
by following the link below the video.
What if the browser doesn't
support the source set attribute?
That's not a problem,
the source set attribute is ignored, and
the image is loaded in the usual
way using the source attribute.
Here I'm opening the page in Firefox,
where the source set attribute
is still behind the flag and
you'll see the 1x version is downloaded
to default from the source attribute.
Turn on the flag, reload and press that.
You can see the source
set attribute in action.
Source set can also be
used with width units.
For a browser,
there's a catch-22 when it comes to
choosing which image to download.
The browser needs to know
the dimensions of each image, but
it can't know that without
downloading each image to check.
Until the mighty W unit.
The W unit tells the browser
the width of each image.
Thereby enabling the browser to
choose the right image to retrieve
depending on the screen pixel
density and the viewport size.
Think about it.
If you have a browser
window sized at say 500
pixels wide on a 2x display and
image 1000 pixels wide,
that's 2 times 500 would be adequate for
any display size in that window.
The point is that we're enabling
the browser to make the right choice
of image since at runtime,
the browser knows the screen size and
pixel density, but not the image size.
Later, you'll see how to work
with image display sizes
that are less then the full
width of the viewport.
Now, you might be wondering,
why width and not height?
Well, width covers most use cases.
But there has been some discussion
of introducing an H unit.
And for the responsive obsessives among
you, follow the link below the video.